it seemed like everybody in Hollywood
came out to celebrate you seems
seems just got started was it sensory
overload when you have all of those
people in one room singing you're crazy
well it was wonderful and embarrassing
at the same time I didn't want a
birthday bash with a cake and I didn't
want to roast what I wanted was a
variety show we would show funny clips I
hope you have Maya Rudolph paying homage
to the iconic Gone With the Wind curtain
dress oh this open
this year's heartfelt message of
gratitude I'd had sunny as a partner and
when I went on my own I was really
frightened and you helped me and you
know you did and these two besties of
more than 60 years side by side for all
the Celeb tributes when Carol Burnett 90
years of laughter and love airs tonight
on NBC you don't have my Chum Julie
Andrews next to me she flew out to be
with me and that was such a thrill so
often you've been the one I've called
when times were rough what started the
Friendship her manager he said you two
girls should meet and of course you know
that's like the kiss of death you know
we say oh you're going to love each
other yeah and then we had a dinner date
with the two gentlemen and Julie and me
well it was like we'd known each other
forever those two poor men never got a
word in edgewise we were like you have
that being like that and so the idea was
born that we should do a special
together and so we wound up doing three
specials over the years hey old friend
we've been with you for such a long time
at Entertainment Tonight I think our
first interview with you was back in
1982. wow yes 1982 and I want to take
you back there oh no
all my Heavens you have to like you
because if you put all your eggs in what
everybody else is going to think about
you's basket uh you're but you're never
yourself I've said it before is to be
untroubled by failure and Untouched by
Triumph
yep
those words are so profound and I wonder
in 1982 what gave you the courage to be
in that space already to do things the
way you wanted to do them and Forge your
own path it was the only way I could be
happy people may forget what you said
people may forget what you did
but they will always remember how you
made them feel
[Music]
it doesn't take much effort just to
become
smile is much nicer isn't it though what
is there left for you to do I don't even
know is there one thing left for you to
do
what happened because we're thinking the
same thing I've heard you saying
is it true what's going on between you
and George Clooney would be interesting
it's not a bad thing left on The Bucket
List
I think Mr Clooney might be game too
I haven't heard from him so I don't know
if he's interested you know
[Music]